Gaming is just the best I mean where
else can you put on a headset and call
some of the newbies just you and feel
really superior about it and then talk
about their mom instead no Gaming is
seriously the best where else can you
feel more alive than paying for the
chance of maybe getting that rare item
unlocking this chest is the only way I
feel alive anymore
Yanks no okay
Gaming is just the best I'm waiting for
the next MOBA to be announced so I can
start practicing and become the best and
hopefully it'll be popular like League
of Legends and have great eSports
potential now we're starting over
Gaming is just the worst we love games
we live for games we are sick to death
of some things in games video games are
in a weird spot if you think about it
one where commercialism creativity
technology art philosophy all collide
head-on we want new experiences and
games but have to call upon our
collective history with them in order to
be proficient at them games have to sell
when these pressures mix together with
some bonus complacency thrown in
nefarious trends emerge at first we
think nothing of them but over time we
start to get enraged by them yelling at
our screens and our connects in hopes
that if the NSA is listening they can
pass on our crass messages to the
offending games developers or we can
make a video about them and that is what
this is let's start with some small ones
like pinging the game world to highlight
loot or meaningless objects of interest
it's like developers are afraid to have
the player wander around the world
without something active for them to be
doing nothing breaks any illusion of
immersion more than constantly sending
out little pings as you wander around
also gamer vision it's difficult to be
completely aware of your surroundings in
a video game
I get that our awareness is very limited
so it makes sense that the characters we
play would have an alternate vision
thing to kind of bridge that gap it's a
concession that's understandable the
first time but after a while I just miss
it being motivated by a gadget like in
Splinter Cell ok so a little immersion
braking isn't that bothersome to you huh
well what about
I sit throws dead if three controllers
lasted way longer is it a day of the
week well then a new mobo was just
announced yesterday based on the wild
success of dota and League everyone
wants in the MOBA game but it's not
likely that any of them will carry the
torch the way these behemoths of eSports
do let alone have any eSports fallen but
that won't stop developers from
shoutcasting every game of everything at
conventions in order to show you the
east-west potential on display of their
latest wares so what makes a publisher
think their latest game with zero
pedigree will convince the community to
believe in it and learn its intricacies
in order for an eSports scene to develop
its the eSports bucks it's always that
eSports bucks so few games will actually
have big tournaments and rabid
spectators let those things come
naturally and focus on what your game
does best there's nothing more desperate
than the eSports plea
do you have too much money well have we
got some games for you ones where you
collect in-game currency but you can
also buy currency using your in real
life money oh and these games already
set you back full retail price
free-to-play games have this setup and
yeah that's a whole other conversation
but it's bleeding into paid games where
in-game items XP boosts and the like are
purchasable with cold hard cash that's a
dangerous game
what if enough people actually do this
and the publishers see it as a viable
revenue stream more and more content
will be locked behind a steep time or
real money investment and this is a
trend that will leave us all more poor
skimpy armor has got to go strapping
female characters into tiny metal bras
and thongs isn't going to protect them
from whatever projectiles are magic
being flung at them first and foremost
boob armor is dangerous molding metal
around a breast is a bad idea if your
lady warrior gets hit in the chest the
sharp angles of the boob armor will
allow it to dig into her flesh and crush
her sternum effectively killing her same
goes for dudes wearing leather pants and
metal plates that conveniently open to
expose their hairless shiny chests means
they're as good as dead if we're going
to be portraying heroine battles and
lifelike combat in video games even with
all those weird physics and wizard duels
we need to be better about how we outfit
our characters no one wearing armor that
lovingly molds to their boobs but
exposes their belly button is going to
make it out of that alive
you know Peter I can't find Rob so tell
me about it the most the trends you
think needs to die video games dude
there's a lot you just start up your
game you're about to enter this
fantastical world that takes place in
something that is totally unlike reality
and the game says what do you want the
character's name to be well I don't have
a clue to choose a name based on nothing
so you say okay well what's my real
world like what can you know what can I
look to you Steve
dan asking me to choose the name of a
character before I start a game is like
giving me a homework assignment that I
don't want
here's one for you so you're playing an
RPG and you pick up a lot of items right
half of them are just junk that you're
never going to use that's not that fun
are you doing that because you want me
to find the rarer items and then feel
better about having those probably but
if you were doing your job right as a
game developer wouldn't every item feel
special wouldn't everything be a great
you know reward for all the progress
I've made rather than picking up a gray
common item that doesn't mean jack all
according
you